- C'est la vedette de la NASA
mais ses jours sont comptés :
en 2031, la Station spatiale
internationale sera
entièrement détruite.
Planétarium Rio Tinto- Ça fait ,
qu'elle tourne au-dessus de
nos têtes, qu'ondes contacdes cc
les astronautes qui sont en
place dans la station et, oui,
le fait de savoir qu'elle va
pincement au coeur, quand même.
- À la fois laboratoire
flottant, banc d'essai
pour nouvelles technologies
et aubercette station de 400 to,
qui orbite la Terre à toutes
les 90 minutes, souffre
de deux maladie incurables :
sa monstrueuse facture annuelle.
spatiale Agence spatiale canad.
- Il y a le vieillissement p
ensuite, il y a le coût.
La NASA, sur un budget
de 23 milliards de dollars US,
dépense milliards
pour l'entretien et
les expériences sur la Station
- La Station se trouve
À partir de 2027, elle va
progressivement s'
de la Terre, jusqu'au point
de non-retour, en 2030.
la rentrée dans l'atmosphère,
tégration et la chute
dans l'océan Pacifique,
au point NEMO, qui sert
qu'une partie de la Stationva be
et puis ce qui va rester
va venir s'écraserndroit-là, en.
dans un cimetière, en fait,
de satellites.in the repressuri.
- La NASA a été claire :
elle ne construira plus
de station en basse orbite.
privée qui va le faire.
- On passe d'un monde où
c'étaient les agences spatiales
qui étaient celles qui
les infrastructures en orbite
à un monde où, maintenant,
des entreprises commerciales.
- Une demi-douzain
de projets se précisent.
est le plus ambitieux.
C'est presque un pge,
avec ses quartiers réservés pour
les chercheurs, les astronautes
et les touristes. Le projet de
plus réaliste à court terme.
Et celuilanifie de se
greffer à la station existante,
avant de s'en détacher.
de la NASA va transformer
le programme spatial du Canada.
- L'Agence spatiale canadienne
ir un client
de plateforme commerciale,
au même titre que la NASA
et les autres partenaires.
Donc, c'est important pour nous
de... non seulement de suivre
l'évolution, mais de commencer
à nous positionner.
- En l'absence quasi-totale
de réglementation dans l'espace,
la multiplication des stations
pourrait également créer
de nouveaux défis.
- Il va y avoir comme une espèce
d'autorégulation propre,
, ça peut , ça peut , ça peut ,e
inquiétant parce qu'on laisse
l'espace, encore une fois, au
privé puis l'espace n'appartient
pas aux Elon Musk de ce monde.
- La NASA vient d'accorder
plus de 400 millions de dollars
en subventions à trois projets
de construction de stations
spatiales privées.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon